[Music]
foreign
the most important episode The Dawn is
looking at the life of Donna everything
no we're going to be looking at the book
dawn of everything well since we're
talking about the origin of society I
have an origin story
okay ooh does it involve a bang not
agriculture
but booze because humans figured out how
fermentation worked
and they didn't want to leave the
fermentation process so instead of
Hunter Gathering they decided to sit
there and guard their stash against the
other hobsian brutes so that they could
get drunk by the end of it and this of
course leads to the cultivation of
barley and hops
fermenting beer and wine and this is why
people decided to settle in one place
oh that's funny there's a parallel with
elephants elephants
I was gonna say I've heard this one
for a long time actually it was a
University of Calgary researcher who
figured this out because people thought
now there's no way elephants could get
drunk they have way too high of a body
mass they would have to
you know just drink like a guzzle a
barrel right but apparently they do not
have one of those enzymes required or
one of the ends items that we have that
breaks down alcohol so they can get
drunk despite their massive
body size so they're easy they're easy
drunks
if you're looking for a date head to the
zoo hit up the elephants
they're cheap dates but if we're looking
for parallels with early primates you
know elephants travel together what if
they're just traveling from their booze
Dash to boost Dash because they haven't
figured out how to how to cultivate yet
clearly the origins of sedentary Society
were being just too wasted to move
around or waiting for your booze to
finish it sounds reasonable we solved it
the dawn of the dusk of everything here
we are a literal social lubricant
indeed and because we can just make
things up now
that's what I'm gonna make up
way into this sort of topic is just like
uh I guess inequality
also we talked about inequality last
week that's the topic again in a way
what it is where it came from
sort of
let's ask you Victor you're as a
political philosopher
this is like what we'd call early modern
political philosophy but it goes back to
Plato and perhaps before
but is this the kind of the point when
inequality becomes even a concept in
political Theory or is there any
precursor in Islamic or medieval
philosophy so I thought that would
definitely be a field where I lack uh
knowledge
in Islamic I mean the thing is so much
of Islamic philosophy was kind of
neo-aristotelianism
um yeah example
yeah there was one class that I tied for
and I really like I I can't remember for
the life of me like the the specifics of
that
but inequality is a concept I mean look
Aristotle worried about it
um he just worried about the fact that
if you had too much basically like
polarization then you would have you
would lack stability in the regime right
it's like that but like
inequality was not like seen as a puzzle
in the sense of like why do we have so
much of it more just well what are the
things that could threaten the stability
of a city-state of a polis and Aristotle
was worried that if you have too much
inequality
then you're going to happen of course I
mean I gotta say like even looking back
to Plato his whole story of how regimes
fall
I mean in some ways like it's it it
turned out to be quite an accurate
account in many ways I mean if you you
know you could describe the French
Revolution as as almost being like a
case study in
like like first you have a tyrant or
like a tyranny I forgot the exact name
that Plato used right back then but and
then you have uh the the uh the people
like like bringing in democracy which of
course if Plato saw as chaotic and
horrible and then what's the problem
with democracy it's like then you'll
have a strong man who comes in and takes
advantage of it and then like becomes a
leader Napoleon right and it's like so
you can you can kind of see that pattern
happening and of course the whole to
connect it back to inequality I mean
Aristotle was just worried about I think
Aristotle and Plato had similar accounts
like of regimes with slight
modifications and just worried about the
conditions under which they would
destabilize and definitely inequality
was something that Aristotle paid
attention to in the Politics as
something that could lead to crisis
which is why the thing that he
ultimately advocates for is like this
mixed regime right where you have like
aspects of democracy and aspects of
oligarchy because then you can have a
Max you can maximize basically a middle
class I mean all like he didn't use that
language and he wouldn't have known
class politics but ultimately he was
like a middle class middle people is
like the translation
uh are like a stabilizing force a middle
mob
exactly what about what about this claim
uh I'm jumping ahead but it it pertains
to this what about this claim that it's
almost impossible to find this is a
quote it's almost impossible to find a
single European author before the 19th
century who suggested that it would be
anything other than a terrible form of
government at I.E democracy as I say
democracy might have been invented in
Europe uh lest we forget that ancient
Greece is in Europe although they note
that much more closely culturally
connected to North Africa and the Middle
East at the time
yep
um so the Democracy may have been
invented there and whatever Athens in
the fourth fifth century uh but it was
considered a horrible idea until the
19th century by almost every single
European author
uh that's interesting isn't it I mean
that's like it that doesn't completely
go against what well
I don't think
I agree that that's true to an extent
but also where that can kind of become a
little bit missing misunderstood from
our modern perspective is what they mean
by democracy is really different than
what we mean by democracy and they and
like so for uh from an Athenian
perspective like so obviously it only
includes men and and you know non-slaves
land owning but but well non-slaves I
think I don't know if land ownership was
necessarily you just have to be a free
person and a citizen
and a man but
uh but also like the form of democracy
like in terms of the institutions of it
like today when we think of democracy
we think about liberal democracy right
elections but if you actually read
Aristotle for him elections are not
actually an aspect of democracy for him
elections are oligarchy because you're
like using elections to select a few
people to rule so for them it was like
who are the people who are actually
exerting political Authority and ruling
democracy would be like a rule of all so
everyone will be exerting direct
political Authority and yeah they
thought that was a terrible idea
um which is why
uh which is why like ultimately what
Aristotle recommends I would argue is
not that different than liberal
democracy like he says you need a mixed
regime that has aspects of democracy and
aspects of oligarchy
um and he and he said that's the best
because it creates a balance
so to some extent yes I would say they
were against democracy but in another
sense
if to a a kind of generalist audience
which I think this book was targeted I
think the way they frame it is slightly
misleading because what they actually
thought of as democracy would be not
something we would recognize as
democracy today it's something much more
radical where everyone is exerting
direct politicalness or every citizen is
exerting or you could at least do a
lottery authortition which you as maybe
some of you know from a long time ago
I'm kind of supportive of that's
actually associated with democracy for
the ancient Greeks but certainly not
elections
yeah the mob as this Cesspool of
appetites and reaction and desires
that's the the mob is the threat to the
stable political order yeah
which is true by the way
yeah well I mean how do you that this
goes into some of the arguments right
it's like how can you imagine a direct
democracy with countries with so many
people in them right like we have a
couple examples like uh like Switzerland
and Germany they they preserve a direct
democracy element in that you can prove
you can present a law if you get say I
think it's in Switzerland it's like 20
000 signatures or something like that
then you could actually forward a law it
doesn't have to come from
whatever the house Congress like people
can get together and propose bills uh we
we don't really have that in in North
America
um all the laws have to sort of be
proposed by the elected representatives
who form the the House of Commons or
whatever Switzerland is a great example
I I like a lot of their institutions
although interestingly they didn't give
women the vote until the 1970s because
and that's probably a consequence of
their direct Democratic systems right
because the men were the only one who
could vote and it took them a really
long time to be like fine let's give the
women the vote
yeah and then I mean this question of of
inequality also kind of runs up against
are the forms of equality that we see
today inevitable from social progress
that's another
I think that's another have we been have
we even said what we've read yet have we
even told the audience I mean I guess
it'll be in the title I think uh yeah
yeah well wengro and graber's book the
dawn of everything published a couple
years ago The Davids The Davids I'll be
calling them at least the Davids
uh they published this book and yeah one
of I already mentioned one of their
questions like the origin of inequality
as a discourse in a in a way when it
becomes it becomes so important in the
in the 18th and 19th century and as I
mentioned they claim that before then
democracy which which maybe shouldn't
conflate with equality uh was looked at
as a bad form of government until the
19th century after
well many many years of of discussing
these ideas but then their other
question is is then the forms of
equality inequality we see today
based on some ways of of approaching
history
some people would claim that these are
you know necessary forms
these are sacrifices that have to be
made in order to have you know a
functioning Society with so many people
in them where you need centralized forms
of government you need Authority you
need bureaucracy
um otherwise everything would fall apart
and unfortunately you know some of the
consequences of of having this are you
know some people are going to be
unhoused some people are going to be at
the bottom of the of the food chain so
to speak
and
their challenges is to say can we can we
imagine another form of society right
like you know it's easier to imagine the
end of the world than the end of
capitalism blah blah but it appears we
are at a moment in time where we do need
to make changes and that and they go
back really far to demonstrate that
these forms of social inequality are not
necessary that in fact they are you know
part of a dynamic and experimental
Social Development that kind of got
stuck at some point in history we kind
of got stuck and part of our stuckness
is the way we look back
and see our own progress and then the
lenses are are Rousseau and Hobbes
largely for that so like I understand
they're kind of poking holes in the sort
of standard story some of which I found
really interesting and convincing other
things I think are like based on a
slight misreading of certain things that
I'm like less sure about but but I don't
know what the argument is so like I
don't know if that guy like because you
were kind of talking there made it sound
like you knew what the argument was so
maybe I missed it in the introduction I
think or well what I was just saying and
then we'll go I think what I was just
saying really was that they're trying to
open this question up I think that's
their okay so there's not actually an
argument for why we don't need let's say
like any like hierarchical structures
because I was looking for that argument
but it seems to be just implicit between
the lines and I was like well maybe it
comes later in the book it probably does
they're questioning the idea about we
why people are claiming that we do need
those structures that's what they're
attacking they're not saying that
hierarchy is unnecessary or always bad
they're just saying why do some people
think it's completely and utterly
inevitable okay inevitable and that
hierarchy goes along with inequality and
social stratification they're saying
those are those unequal social
arrangements are something that we've
just kind of
written off in a way right we write off
inequality that as a necessary sacrifice
to maintain you know our current social
organization which is necessary and
inevitable based on social history blah
blah blah okay sorry pills what were you
saying I wanted to just rehash what the
common story is
um and when I when I was when I was
reading this this came to mind when I
was in sixth grade how old are you in
sixth grade like 11 something like that
um I think it's plus five or six years
usually we had this like little history
textbook with a bunch of pictures and
one of the assignments which I remember
vividly was we had to make a comic strip
uh it had six
frames six stages and it was the first
one was hunter gatherers so we had to
like draw hunter-gatherers and then they
stripped the bark off trees and started
like burning forests I guess
um and then stage three was agriculture
I can't remember the last three but this
is the common story is for a hundred
thousand years nothing happened then all
of a sudden you have Agriculture and
then you have Sumer and Egypt and these
giant settlements that produce you know
grain because there's grain it allows
you to have an upper class or a Priestly
class religion is produced and this is
kind of these stages stagific narrative
and despite this not having a whole lot
of empirical evidence to support it
anymore or a lot more evidence that
doesn't fit into this six stage story of
how we arrived at the present most
people believe it and then Stephen
Pinker
that a adrenochrome sucking vampire but
people like people like Stephen Pinker
just rehash this narrative
um they brought up in this in this
chapter of course capitalist apologists
rehashed this narrative as like the most
natural thing in the world is to produce
a market right and to have yeah to turn
to turn into money and to have trade and
then civilization grows out of these
nodes of trade with hierarchy with
priests with Kings and so this physical
economy beliefs classic political
economy beliefs so this is just the main
story and they want to say we could if
we actually looked at the evidence and
there's a bunch of new evidence
apparently in their fields one's an
archaeologist the other's what an
anthropologist
so if we looked at the evidence then we
would see no they were actually
experimenting they tried different
things they these supposedly independent
nomadic hunter gatherer bands like met
up for these giant cultural events in
certain places so basically it's a myth
it's a myth busting or a picture of is
wrong and what I liked about it too is
the way they also talk about how because
because in that traditional story it's
like oh when we were hunter-gatherer
bands that's when we had egalitarianism
that's when we were equal but in small
groups and what I like about what they
say is like
that's enough first a that might not be
the only formation where that's possible
but also b a lot of hunter-gatherers
probably weren't egalitarian either
right so they kind of like are like stop
over romanticizing and under
romanticizing kind of like the past like
sort of both sides are kind of making a
mistake I also liked the way that they
talked about the kind of cherry picking
of particularly violent examples of
tribes right that like some like try to
make an argument for how the state of
nature is some kind of really violent
place and that also reminded me of I
remember a long time ago reading this
book uh the sex at dawn which was about
like the prehistoric origins of human
sexuality and that book I think has
gotten a lot of criticism later but one
of the things like I really liked about
it is they did something sort of similar
rhetorically where they're like look at
this standard story that pushes monogamy
and they kind of like offer this
different evidence but one of the things
they point out is like a lot of people
like to talk about chimpanzees and I've
seen Jordan Peterson [__] do this
like not even that long ago like talk
about chimpanzees to like look at their
violent tendencies and their kind of
like territorial Tendencies but there's
also [__] bonobos who were just as
related to right and they have a totally
different social structure they are like
all about free love and like have sex
with each other and don't really like
have much conflict and
they're actually the only other primate
that actually has missionary sex which
is really weird
very bizarre like uh they're they're
basically like pygmy chimps and uh
anyway so like it just reminds me of how
like like we always hear stories about
like the violent tribes or like we only
hear stories of like the violent
chimpanzees but it's like this other
side the bonobos no one talks about but
they tell you a different story about
human nature if you wanna but but what I
would also say by the way is just using
chimpanzees or bonobos or even tribes to
try to generalize about human beings is
I mean tribes makes more sense but like
especially applies to chimpanzees or
bonobos like I don't think you can make
any conclusions about human beings by
looking at them at all so that's also
just stupid another thing we do is use
like uncontacted uncivilized tribes that
still exist today
capsules of our ancestors so basically
they're just saying you know whatever
you think you're thinking of in
cardboard cutouts and everything you say
about it you can complicate it but they
say at one point anything you can
imagine about how different our cultures
are today it's the same then we're all
modern humans even even 10 000 years ago
yeah I think they mentioned that even
like our brain structures haven't really
like in evolutionary terms our brain
structures haven't changed for many many
thousands of years and so you know those
pre-pre-historic people who we call
primitive are us they have the same
brain the same Anatomy they just have a
different situation obviously but
they're they they're mental life their
intelligence they're just as capable as
as modern people like they're the same
but just in a radically different
context they have an imagination
innocent children as some people like to
call them they have an imaginary full of
myths that they self-justify and they
probably have true believers who believe
in the random mythology people who don't
believe as much but we have all of our
modern mythologies if you've seen any of
any of my contacts also quick quick I
want to just say I'm just going to say a
quick quick little aside like which I
just listened to so I think a little bit
later in the book they also talk about
how really really early humans if you
look at the archaeological evidence were
coexisting with a bunch of other human
species and then I thought it was like I
never thought of it this way but they
were like like it would have looked a
lot similar to like what you see in
Middle Earth like in the sense that
you'd see like dwarves like giants just
like really different human species and
you can even find archaeological
evidence of like basically modern-ish
humans like coexisting with these pygmy
like other like Homo Sapien style like
smaller brains and it just would have
been a totally different world than
social structure to have like multiple
human species Middle Earth neanderthals
right yeah neanderthals but also other
ones and it's just really interesting to
think about a world where you have
multiple sentient human species
coexisting and it would be more like a
fantasy world of like dwarves and elves
and like whatever like coexisting kind
of different human species I never
thought of it with that kind of uh
analogy before but anyway it's really
hard to even picture this to put the
concepts into images like the fact that
blew my mind a little bit was there's
this cave in Spain we've probably seen
it where they have the the animals and
the handprints painted on the walls and
these paintings were done like 10 000
years apart so you're doing 25
000 to like 10 000 BC or something yeah
you're doing the same thing you have a
similar or relatable social structure
and similar or relatable rituals to your
ancestors 10 000 years prior which as
moderns it's impossible or at least for
me it's impossible to conceive of a time
scale that's that relatable in terms of
the past to the present and and really I
think what our future Generations are
going to have to even grapple with too
is that it's even impossible now to
perform an isolated act like literally
anything you do is going to be broadcast
to the corners of the earth immediately
right like look at these people painting
for ten thousand years someone else on
the other side of the planet no [__]
idea what they're doing they are not
building on their style they're not
creating an artistic tradition it's
local
right so we have this globalization to
deal with which is I mean even in the
whole 20th century it's very difficult
to get out of that mind frame and and
look at this stuff in its local
specificity but also taking into account
movement and displacement but in a
non-globalized context where information
doesn't travel like viruses and beams of
at the speed of light
so I came to this book with a really
open mind I'd heard about it uh heard
some of the summary but we got to get
into the we've been planning to look at
it for a while we got to get into the
division that they set up which is
there's two options that are not them
but two options to look at this period
which is the hobbsian and the russoyan
and then suddenly they're on our turf so
I don't know which what you guys are
gonna say about it but I came to this so
hoping that I would just be like yes
this is an artistic imaginative new
painting of the past but I get stuck on
these details so I had a big problem
with how they handled Rousseau
considering we read Rousseau last week
so it was fresh in my mind I don't know
if Hobbes you could object similarly I
had I had some issues with their Hobbes
reading too but anyway go ahead all
right yeah but I hate I hate that I
didn't want to read like that I don't
want to think like that but you know
training is training is hard to overcome
so covering Rousseau last week for
example I kind of funny I find it kind
of funny that they chose him as this
foil say nothing really positive or
defensive except uh you know here and
there but the purpose of their book in
general is so incredibly rousseauian it
couldn't be more Rousseau if they had
read more than just one chapter of one
discourse that you submitted for an
essay contest
so when it comes to like they say in the
beginning basically is a thesis
statement we need to have a new
political imagination we need to expand
the imagination
and they said here's a direct quote in
the end we decided to write a book that
would Echo to some degree at least that
evolution in our own thought in these
those conversations the real
breakthrough moment came when we decided
to move away from European thinkers like
Rousseau entirely
but this is they basically then quote
Russo not the discourse of inequality
But A Book Like a meal perhaps when they
say what if we treat people from the
beginning as imaginative intelligent
playful creatures who deserve to be
understood as such What If instead of
telling a story about how our species
fell from an idyllic state of equality
we asked how he came to be trapped in
such tight conceptual shackles that we
can no longer even imagine the
possibility of Reinventing ourselves so
all of this language
Reinventing yourself having a new
imagination Freedom creativity this is
practically a direct quotation of
something Russo would have said
including in the origin of inequality
and a meal this is a combo that the
modern human is not just this rational
scientifically obsessed animal but one
who desires Freedom one whose happiness
comes from imagination and creativity so
this is why I thought you know you can't
just [__] on Rousseau your entire book
when your thesis statement could be
taken from the book that you're [__]
on yeah I mean yeah I mean that's
exactly what Rousseau is kind of saying
in in the sense that we you know we we
have this initial freedom and in order
to preserve that freedom we run headlong
into our chains which is to say you know
government and bureaucracy and and and
sort of EX extra personal social
organizations that don't involve
face-to-face relationships so much as as
you know controls and and and rules and
things like that and
yeah so it sounds like that they're kind
of reproducing that like what if instead
of saying how it fell from some kind of
Eden right like that's what he want they
want to get rid of the Eden side right
because because Rousseau's story is is
uncannily close to a Garden of Eden
right where you live in this perfect
world and then original sin befalls you
and then suddenly you're out roving like
hunter-gatherers until a second tragedy
hits which is agriculture or in in
someone like pinkers and a more uh
hobsian vein it's this city-state the
city emerges as the locus of inequality
right where you have bureaucracies like
there's two sides to this like that's
the the general development right from
from tribes to bands to chiefdoms and to
then to like City bureaucracies and and
kingships and things like that
where we have this linear story and
they're trying to get rid of that but
almost preserve that innocence that
Rousseau was talking about that sort of
creative passionate exuberance for
social experimentation they're trying to
preserve that without saying that it it
necessarily implies moving into forms of
hierarchy and dominance right like
what's like Rousseau's story is that you
know
like a lot of people repeating Russo's
story like Jared diamond and Francis
fukiyama say yeah that that state was
great that state of nature you know we
lived in these little bands it's all
egalitarian but come on grow up be real
be real man be a man we need leadership
we need hierarchy we need we need a
chain of command and big populations
need chains of commands so these things
are necessary evils and then from the
habibian point of view these things are
actually preventing the state of war
that everybody seems to kind of revert
to if if Society kind of lapses we
revert back into a state of nature where
it's Bellum Omni the war of all against
all kind of thing so Victor you've read
Hobbes recently as their reading of
Hobbes similar to that I mean of course
when you're writing a book you need to
set up foils
you know what it's a little bit too much
of a foil because you could have read
the rest of you could have read the rest
of the discourse and you would have see
clearly that Rousseau says
you know agriculture came to the aid of
these other Arts that were being
developed agriculture did not come first
actually yeah I think Hobbs is like I
think it's okay I also felt that look
they need a foil they're kind of giving
a generalized understanding of both of
them I think with Hobbes there's just a
couple things where I was like uh like I
don't know like I think that there's but
this is a common like misunderstanding I
think like the emphasis on a war of all
against all like
this is not really I think what's often
over emphasized in a hobbiesian account
is like selfishness
self-interest and like aggression war of
all against all when really I would say
like the central thing and I was
actually listening carefully for it and
I don't think they said it but Hobbes
and he even says this I mean the main
the main motivating feature it's not
exactly selfishness but fear like it's
like literally like you're afraid and I
think that makes a difference in your
interpretation and it's like when
there's no structure to secure your
safety and well-being then you're gonna
be motivated by fear and the reason it's
described as a war of all against all is
because even if you make an agreement
with someone right that's why he talks
about you know um Compact and all this
stuff in in in Leviathan and it's like
it's just the fact you have no certainty
That Someone's Not Just Gonna backstab
you the next day and that makes it kind
of a psychological war of all against
all because you're just never sure
there's nothing to to to to guarantee
that that person isn't going to
eventually backstab you even though
interestingly Hobbes does say in the
state of nature like most will be
cooperative and most should be
cooperative but the problem is that you
never know and because we're so
motivated by fear
that you so I think like it's okay I
understand you take the nasty brutish
short quotes and you take the war of all
against all quote and like I get that
this is a common misunderstanding by not
like a non-theorist outside of political
Theory to describe it that way but when
you actually look at what he's saying
it's a little bit more nuanced but I'm
but I want to be forgiving for that and
I think but I do think that the more
nuanced argument is a little bit more
convincing it's a little bit more
interesting because I think there is
something to that to the idea of fear
like when you don't have any structure
like that makes way more sense to me
than oh human beings are selfish
therefore they're going to be aggressive
against each other that's a really
different story than just we're all
afraid and interestingly the other thing
that in Hobbes that makes him similar to
Russo is he also thinks that people are
equal in the state of nature right and
but but they're equal in their equal
ability to kill you right like even
women right because we're smart and we
all have the equal ability to outsmart
each other and there's always an equal
potential to be outsmarted by somebody
um it's obviously very different account
of equality but I thought it's also
worth mentioning that to some extent
Hobbes also agrees that there was a
quality in the state of nature just not
in the same way yeah that Rousseau
thought that there is equality that
really changes the interpretation of
Hobbes from nasty brutish and short like
you're going to be literally killed
instead it's more like you might get
killed scared probably not but your
biggest fear is the guy that you're
making a contract with is going to break
the contract so that's why you need a
Levine and there's no and there's no
recourse exactly and then there's no
reason so you need you need a legal
system to protect that contract kind of
thing exactly an impersonal whole system
of rule but like the point is the point
is for Hobbes those impersonal systems
of rule are curbing our natural
selfishness right I don't think
the state of nature ceases to exist
right like it's again for Hobbes it's he
I mean I think in here they mentioned he
almost suggests this is literal human
history but not quite he's still sort of
on the side of this is orthotics he
Hedges yeah and so he thinks humans like
I've I've seen readings of Hobbes saying
yeah he believes humans are naturally
selfish and without these you know
governmental mechanisms you know those
those Tendencies would tend to come to
the fore so we need so there's your sort
of liberal Theory where it's it's um
legal systems are meant to you know
mediate conflicts between people right
as opposed to the russoian view where
those things are are more like
repressive right like almost like like
almost in the way Freud kind of re-reads
this story is that so entering into
civilization is necessarily entering
into a form of repression where you're
sort of natural innocence and and and
these and these sorts of hunter-gatherer
egalitarian Tendencies then gets kind of
redirected into hierarchies and and then
and again this is necessary in order to
live together in big societies but it
has the opposite effect instead of
curbing a a state of nature in which you
know the selfishness dominates it's
curbing a state of nature in which you
know sort of an egalitarian freedom
is nice and it's great but it prevents
us from from achieving these larger
social organizations so that again for
Rousseau agriculture kind of does this
it forces us to come together and stay
together and make organizations and
creates private property and then for
more Hobbes influenced kind of view it's
the city right the city the centralized
government the bureaucracy that's the
origin of inequality and and what
they're saying is that's not true in
either sense right before in the in the
egalitarian social small societies right
hunter-gatherers we can find both
egalitarian and inegalitarian
hunter-gatherers
snap forward to the city we can find
both egalitarian and inegalitarian
social organizations of cities go to
agriculture we can find agriculture
becoming a permanent thing we can find
agriculture being sort of just a
sporadic temporary thing we can find
people who dabble with Agriculture and
then [__] reject it entirely and go
back to hunting and Gathering again he
says that they say that the problem is
with the linearity of all of these
stories they're linear they assume
they're stages there's there's many
different versions of stage Theory and
they say this is just not the right way
to look at history and so that the
Hobbes were so
choice is not you could blend their
decisions together and make a really
nuanced Theory but they're saying like
first of all the fact that they got it
right with a guess hundreds of years ago
and that we can't improve on those
guesses is a ridiculous idea and second
of all the either or between them is a
false binary you can't look at it as
either one or the other egalitarian
before in egalitarian after or vice
versa you cannot do that that is not
what the evidence like that doesn't fit
they'll always be large swaths of
evidence that don't fit either of those
stories and so what do we got to do we
got to tell a completely different
[__] story get rid of the Garden of
Eden get rid of the the John Wick kind
of war against all and we just gotta
retell this story and what they their
problem is
we haven't come up with a news story
that's super memorable right like bands
tribes Chieftains agriculture cities
that's very easy and memorable but we
haven't come up with anything better to
put in that place so people still go
back to the story even though the the
the
archaeologists working today the experts
in the field actually have kind of
privileged access to this new
data that controverts these stories but
it's very difficult that that's the
effort they're trying to do now is right
this popular book get these ideas out
there and they they've been accused
exactly of cherry picking but what you
were saying before they say they
actually say here's what we can do with
cherry picking you know Francis fukuyama
or Stephen Pinker says this okay let's
look at their let's cherry pick a
different story instead and go back
here's a dwarf buried in a lavish burial
what does that show us that shows us
that ancient societies were caring they
were based on care if people were
suffering they would do stuff for them
so see how cherry picking if you just
generalize from cherry picking you'll
get all kinds of these fun stories but
they will be wrong because you're just
not you're just ignoring other pieces of
evidence that controverted
I mean it's it's the complexity of the
history that's that's the problem
and the simplifications of Rousseau and
Hobbes
not not them specifically because yeah
it is a misreading of them to look at
them as talking about literal world
history but those those stories have
kind of been literalized and taken up
whether it's by Stephen Pinker or Jared
diamond or Francis fukuyama or any of
the other examples they give oh by the
way Rousseau just straight up says
I have no idea how this happened it's
like we didn't have metal and we didn't
he he keeps talking about corn I don't
doesn't corn come from the Americas the
new world yeah that's right so he keeps
talking about like no corn grows better
in Europe I'm like dude he doesn't know
[__] but he also says yo I don't know
[__] all I know is we didn't have any of
this stuff and then we got it so he's
I don't know I'm I'm being a little bit
defensive of the philosopher here but
later later in the dawn of everything uh
it's funny they actually add some extra
detail to like the whole process I don't
know if you guys got to that point of
like Russo actually entering the contest
and writing that essay and I didn't know
I think I maybe said something wrong in
our last episode because I thought he
came second but he was actually
disqualified
because he went over the word count
and like he was a little too uh and it's
funny the guy who actually won the
discourse of inequality like contest
made like a really stupid religious
comment like like argument about why um
um how like the oh how original sin is
the origin of inequality
ah yes classic so I don't I don't know
how much is if this is just quibbling
like
but do you do you combat an
oversimplification with another
oversimplification no we should be no I
mean we should be focusing on the Real
Enemy here which is of course Stephen
Pinker this [__]
Stephen Baker's like we live we live in
heaven already why are you even trying
to do anything taking money from Peter
Thiel
and then but he completely misrepresents
obviously how did we get here Europe
spread civilization everywhere and now
everywhere from uh China to to
indigenous people in North America
everyone lives better because we have
working toilets and you go yeah okay
okay sure did Europe did civilization
spread from Europe in a sense that's
acceptable but it did so of course
through enslavement exploitation
genocide by
annihilating entire civilizations
and they had you know some legal
squabbles about should we annihilate the
civilization or should we not Cortez
didn't give a [__] Cortez was like if I
read to you from the top of the hill
infidels please convert to Jesus Christ
then you're allowed to kill them after
that happened so anyway this is the
Stephen the Stephen Pinker story is we
have all the Comforts of Modern Life
everything that anyone could want
but of course Stephen Pinker never
addresses the question of uh happiness I
haven't read Stephen Pinker lately but
according to them he never talks about
the question of happiness and he
cherry-picks these examples of how awful
it was before you know there was tribes
doing human sacrifice and ritual battle
where the winner would be right how
awful is this
and I was thinking in terms of this if
you look back at our civilization if a
if an alien Anthropologist digs up
the records of the United States and
watches our news then there'd be like
these people are insane they just
Shooters go into into nurseries and
schools and just Massacre children
weekly these people are absolutely
barbaric so if you're gonna cherry pick
I'm not saying I'm saying to cherry pick
examples of human sacrifice within a
context if you look at us we're not
doing all that much better if you if you
choose to focus on the most uncivilized
Acts
yeah the Pinker Pinker is one of the
examples of the Hobbes influenced
theorist where he sees
cities as the transition not farming
um but yeah the claim is uh
as as wengro and Graber right uh what
follows is to put it bluntly a modern
psychologist making it up as he goes so
he's got he he ain't got [__] uh he he
this is what the cherry picking comes
from oatsy Remember The Iceman
I mean this happened in the early 90s
otsi the ice guy kind of came up he came
up uh he was found you know Frozen with
an arrow in his side and then Stephen
Pinker is just like you know how could
how come they couldn't leave us a corpse
without resorting to Foul Play and he
cites otsi being shot by a arrow and and
then they say okay let's Cherry pit
that's cherry picking let's cherry pick
romito too there's a ten thousand year
old burial of a male with a rare genetic
disorder dwarfism a severe type of
dwarfism
which would have rendered him kind of
one of the uh people who couldn't
contribute to like you know the
community instead we see a
extraordinarily lavish burial for this
person uh the the point is you know the
realities of early human social life are
far more complex this is a quote again
and a good deal more interesting than
any modern state of nature theorist
would ever be likely to guess uh we're
not suggesting we should
you know generalize from this now other
cherry-picked caves we say it's just
look look how easy it is you just look
at a violent burial and say ah state of
nature was violent and then we look at
another one ah state of nature was
egalitarian and based on care and mutual
respect ah Hobbs and Rousseau again but
like this it's this false binary that we
we tend it's it's the crustian you know
bed that we folk Force our human
histories into that [__] them up
but we need some kind of bed we need to
put this [__] to bed somehow but the
evidence is still rolling in the
techniques are improving like what do we
do right now we don't do anything we
just have to say those are wrong let's
keep staying wait then we can decide
what we should build a society like on
Mars or whatever wherever we go colonize
with then we can tell Elon Musk how a
society should be developed when he
finally gets out there another example
that I didn't know about that they
brought up is if you wanna if you want
to go with this story that how do you
explain and they say you can't draw too
much too many conclusions from this but
there's all these stories of you know
Western civilized westerners who are
either adopted because they got lost or
kidnapped by these tribes and then even
given the option to return to to quote
unquote civilization they're like no
it's better here I'm gonna I'm gonna
stay
yeah this was another thing they were
talking about and at that Pinker cited
was this Yanomami girl who who got
taken
um and raised what was it as as uh this
was in prison it was in Brazil I think
yeah he cites the story yeah she gets
abducted and lives with a series of
Yanomami families and Mary's and
actually becomes like a kind of
important member in the community in
1956 she abandoned the Yanomami to go
back to her natal family a western
family only to find herself in quote a
state of occasional hunger and constant
dejection and loneliness and after a
while went
made a fully informed decision to go
back to the yanamami and return to live
with them for the rest of their life the
point of this sort of Pursuit of
Happiness section is that people are
happier with the natives than they are
with the either way right the natives
abduct a white person somehow that white
person is returned to their white family
they don't like it they go back and live
with the natives same thing the other
direction white people abduct a young
Native
raise them
eventually they leave because [__] the
Europeans like that space basically
they're saying the happiness at this
time seemed to be on the side of the
people who are critical of the Europeans
not the Europeans themselves that's what
they seem to be saying about this
happiness section that people are
finding more happiness among
the peoples of yeah I mean I found those
interesting it did I felt like it was
like rhetorically doing maybe a bit too
much work for my taste but maybe I'm
being a little bit nitpicky because you
know they spend a lot of time
criticizing Pinker and all these others
for cherry picking and then they find
like ancient sources that show a cup a
handful of examples of like
you know some Europeans now wanting to
move back to be fair they say
we're not building an argument off this
point but if we were to do what Pinker
is doing we could come to the exact
opposite conclusion yeah yeah totally
yeah the children picking thing right
because we're Pinker even even the he
Cherry Picked even within a piece of
evidence like he stopped the story at oh
yeah you know brutality and then he said
if he continued I guess if Pinker
continued this story she might have
diagnosed her with uh Stockholm syndrome
because she went back to the brutality
at the end all right she chose the brute
the quote-unquote brutality over quote
unquote civilization so she he might
just conclude that she had brain damage
or something no no I mean I'm no fan I'm
no fan of pinker's argument here at all
so I think I think he's just saying like
stopping it where he does and the
evidence he chooses like this is a like
Pinker is telling very Peterson like
stories with this kind of I mean this I
mean but they get I've read some of the
reviews of this book and and that's
exactly the charge they're cherry
picking evidence they're they're being
unfair they're over generalizing they're
this they're that they're what what
whatever Graber and Wenger are doing
that the critics don't like you know but
that seems to be the [__] point is to
say you know cherry picking can produce
all these narratives the original sin
fall from Eden's story whatever we're
fitting the evidence into these
narratives when these are the wrong
narratives to be fitting the evidence
into in the first place and if we're
doing a narrative that we're taught when
we're 12
I'm partial to cherry-picked examples
just to tell a different story for the
sake of it even totally almost like the
narrative out of the stories but to just
show why the other white Pinker stopped
short and cherry-picked like in both
both of his chosen pieces of evidence
yeah no I mean I like uh I like I said
I've been enjoying the book quite a lot
and I think and I like the idea of just
giving another another account of
History I actually did also read
I when I was on a trip I think I was on
my way to Europe
and I had the audiobook for the Francis
fukuyama book actually the like or um
whatever it is like like the origins of
political order
um or whatever and look I mean I I
learned a lot from that book I don't
like like he goes through a lot of
different stuff so like I don't know if
I would put him in the same camp as
Stephen Pinker because like fukuiyama
goes into a lot of detail
um and seems to I mean give a lot of
nuance from what I understand he also
doesn't just focus on North America I
mean he goes back to the thing I learned
most about was just like Chinese
administration like I had no idea how
sophisticated
like like you know thousands like 3000
BC China was in their administrative and
Bureau bureaucratic like organization
um but anyway so like I like these
stories in general and it's it's good to
have another story that comes in and
says well look there's this other
evidence that kind of shows that maybe
these different kinds of things are
possible what I felt like unclear about
and again I mean first a I need to
finish the book and maybe this book just
isn't that but I know that a lot of
anarchists are excited about it and like
I don't because apparently there's some
kind of implicit argument here but I'm
not sure
like what that argument is and maybe
there's not that argument that this is
showing like I guess the only argument
is more like a negative one that
um we shouldn't think that only one form
of organization is possible and okay and
in response to that I would say like I'm
not really sure that serious thinkers
really believe that only one possibility
like that only one thing is possible
um like I don't think that people
you know I think there is a lot of
acknowledgment of different social
structures existing like even before I
read any of this stuff like my
understanding was that that was not
really that controversial of a claim
like there were there are
other kinds of social organizations that
have existed now
we also have to consider our sort of
access to this information is is much
higher because we are in Academia yes
totally totally but I also but then with
the thing that I wonder about is
you know because they do T is a little
bit uh The Davids they tease a little
bit and they say oh like you know maybe
we don't need uh you know any social
like maybe we don't need any overarching
Authority but then they kind of go back
and they'll be like well of course we're
not saying that these indigenous people
didn't have laws right there like they
acknowledged they did have laws they
were just enforced through different
kind of collective mechanisms
um so that's where obviously like kind
of my political science political Theory
hat I get curious because I'm like okay
well what are you actually talking about
like what do you mean by political
Authority what do you mean by hierarchy
you know because it seems to me that
um to say some work social organizations
don't have hierarchy I'm really I'm
looking forward to seeing if they
actually come up with an example because
I don't exactly know what that would
mean right like I actually do think that
the basic Hobbs hobesian question or
dilemma
applies like it seems like a real
argument which is
like I think the reason why you would
even join a tribe is for hobbiesian
reasons because you're afraid to not
have any do not belong to something that
can give you some guarantee and
protection that when you make agreements
and you cooperate with people you're
going to be protected like at its basic
at its most basic level right like not
that you need a sovereign right but like
you need some structure that is going to
protect you you're a little bit
projecting the hob the hobesian social
contract onto those conditions oh sure
yeah sure you don't think of yourself as
a sovereign individual with the choice
to either leave or stay or you're born
there oh of course of course I mean no
one does though like like literally no
one does like no matter what the social
organization is
the point no but sorry but the point
that I'm making is that like that like
that
um argument for why
um you want to stay within an
organization is an argument for that
social organization whatever it is it's
legitimacy right so it's legitimacy is
because it's able to protect you
right and I think that that is
that applies
I think even more importantly is how do
you keep not your life but your
contracts because this is always in
political theory of I mean in political
theory of legitimacy like political
legitimacy is one of the biggest
questions in political Theory like what
it means and I would say that that like
that's like hobbes's point is a question
of legitimacy right and for him the most
important thing is that whatever the
social organization yes he obviously
advocates for like a crazy one
uh is in so far as it can protect you
and protect contracts and agreements
yeah I noticed that the major difference
between Hobbes and Locke was that Hobbes
says The Sovereign must have the will of
the people behind it but the people
can't depose The Sovereign Locke brought
in the idea that that if the Sovereign
is not serving the will of the people
The Sovereign can be deposed Hobbs are
not willing to go that far I mean I mean
people was there legitimacy I sure was
there yeah but well yeah no no but like
my point is actually that for Hobbes
legitimacy doesn't need the people and
what I'm saying like it just needs that
you feel safe like like it's like it
doesn't matter whether or not like
people actually accepted it right just
like that's why you're born into some
tribe or band it doesn't matter that you
didn't choose it it's legitimate in so
far as it can protect you and keep you
safe and one of their very interesting
arguments about Hobbes uh way it's been
interpreted here's a quote some suspect
that hobbs's state of war was really an
allegory for his native England's
descent into Civil War when they were
definitely end quote you know when they
were involved in the in the in what was
it like the 30-year war was that the War
I don't remember which war that is the
English Civil War started at the very
tail end of the 30 Years War which also
featured
what a a quarter of Europe or something
died in that war so if you want a war of
all against all where no one is keeping
their contracts you need to look no
further than what Hobbes was living
through exactly like Hobbs is hobbs's
point is like we all live we all tend to
they make this fun argument here too
um so so Hobbes came close to suggesting
that the state really existed when quote
here's a quote again when he noted how
the only people who weren't under the
ultimate authority of some King
where the Kings themselves and they seem
to be constantly at war with one another
right so if you're not under that that
Authority you're you're kind of in the
state of nature I guess kings are in it
in the sense that they are their own
authorities so they answer to nobody I
guess that's exactly some of that is why
I would say the answer to God that's
divine right but that is precisely the
argument that irrealists make in
international relations Theory right
that's what they say that's why they
like Hobbes because they're like nation
states don't have anything above them
right so nation states are in the state
of nature
otherwise we're in a state of nature
again because he's Above the Law and you
know what's the special thing about
presidents against Kings presidents are
not above the law wow
wow I mean informally in theory okay
well they are they are subject to the
Constitution they're below in America
they act in a way in which they are
above the law many way in many times but
but sure yeah like like the state of
nature is is for Hobbes
is a war against a war against all
against all okay and then Society curbs
that for Rousseau Society is a tragedy
it takes us out of our nice egalitarian
state of nature but it is inevitable
that is why you have
Jared diamond and Francis fukuyama on
the what is it like the they're on one
side of the argument I don't agree with
you on this though this is like not
according to me it's according to that
telling like Rousseau the whole point of
this again I'm returning to defending my
boy again the point of the state of
nature is not that this is a linear
Narrative of History the point is that
lock and lock and Hobbes are over across
the water there saying science reason
civility civility we get better forever
let's banish all metaphor from political
speak because we need to be clear and we
need to do science and we need to be
rational forever and ever and we get
better whereas Rousseau is responding to
that not coming out of nowhere but
responding to that saying this is not
normal the [__] that you're saying
humans need imagination and need
creativity they need some sense of
purpose and Community to be happy so the
thing you're saying is wrong wrong so
just to be like oh we have two options
for world history it's not really what
the debate was even about
but aren't they in a way saying yeah
diamond and fukiyama are misinterpreting
Rousseau they make it clear Rousseau was
engaged in the thought experiment but
like here the classic story right
fukiyama Diamond was the invention of
agriculture and the this is a quote
again the higher population levels it
sustained agriculture brought about a
transition from bands to tribes
accumulation of food surplus this is
also actually the Marxist Marx and
angles make this argument too the
accumulation of fur food surplus well
here's their quote anyway fed population
growth leading try some tribes to become
Chieftains and as some other people will
say you know agriculture is the origin
of private property right and private
property is the source of inequality and
you know the marks and angles sort of
argument is right like these places
create a stock or a horde and there's a
surplus and then as soon as you have a
serp
you enable the division of classes
either way they're wrong that's that's
the claim here both narratives are wrong
I mean it's probably more of a mixture
of both with with more back and forth
and dynamism and experimentation that
seems to be the main point right it's
not a linear narrative either way it's a
messy
experimental back and forth where some
people go forward to agriculture some
people go backwards some people go back
and forth some people even do it within
a yearly cycle as they go back and forth
between different social forms the pro
the point of the whole thing is today
for the anarchists we seem to just think
of our society as just the necessary
outcome of human history and that
nothing can [__] change even though
we have again rampant inequality
whatever sense of the word we haven't
even defined it yet or we have climate
change we have all these problems we
need to imagine a new social form what
the apologists want to offer us is that
reform you know tinkering tinkering with
statistical inequality and statistically
identifiable aspects of inequality we
could Tinker with those we can make it
but we cannot have we cannot imagine a
new social form you know again but
there's nothing here that helps me to
imagine the end of the world than the
end of capitalism but there's there's
literally nothing in the in the
introduction or anything that helps me
understand a different social form that
could actually solve these complex
issues like I've or even what a new
social form would be like literally I
mean maybe that's what I was kind of
asking at the beginning it's like maybe
it comes later in the book but there's
literally nothing in here that helps
with that well we did only read the
first three it might come up in the
conclusion but as it stands The Davids
are going to lose every game of Age of
Empires they ever play yeah
when without a Siege Workshop
by the way I don't I'm not comfortable
like ascribing to at least fukuyama
because I actually read a lot of that
book
like my memory is he actually like
critiques both Hobbes and Rousseau and
thinks they're both wrong about the
origins of uh human like if my memory is
you know he thinks that like the state
of nature would have actually been a lot
of reciprocal kind of like communal
societies and that like they would no
one would have been isolated right both
Hobbes and Rousseau have this weird
individualist perspective of the state
of nature but setting that aside like I
am just interested in why you think this
actually helps us imagine something
different
because
and this is what I've been sort of
saying in a different version earlier
because it breaks us out of the the
mindset that this is natural or
inevitable or you know the old political
economy view of the market right it is
the natural outcome
of Human Social organization
that's I think
I mean if there were there are many
takeaways I don't think that we're stuck
in a situation thinking that nothing can
change because we read too much Russo
and Hobbes there's a lot more effects
yeah well not because we read too much
Russo and Hobbes right it's because of
this flattening out and literalizing of
their narratives right yeah it's not an
idea it's not an ideas thing it's an
organization thing so Victor's asking
how do you change the organization by
knowing this now
well then okay then I don't know look
out for next year's Nobel Prize because
whoever offers that is gonna win [__]
all of them but my question is but but
is there a model in the archaeological
evidence that helps that's what I'm
trying to figure out no no I would say
okay no there is not
it's one of those it could have been
otherwise thus it can be otherwise
books and I don't want to fall back
simply to the lazy critique of wow what
do we do with this tell me what to do
dads David dads but I don't know it's
still legit I'm getting tired of if we
just had more ideas then the world
wouldn't have looked like this ideas
don't matter
because none of this was anyway an
argumentative or rational process but
speaking of inevitability I wanted to
make sure we got this in there they do
take a shift to homo economicus which I
was happy to read Because capitalist
apologists do this in every argument
whether they have some idea what they're
talking about or none is that humans
naturally form markets and even more
than that sometimes the market is an
eternal form and the ultimate governing
form of human behavior all the way back
to the Stone Age when they were trading
leather for fish or whatever I've heard
personally I've heard this like repeated
over and over again and then one of
their examples is people will point to
evidence like oh look there's shells
from Mexico
in Ohio so these bands must have been
using these shells as currency and they
say well first of all we have three
different options that are not Market
based for this and I found this pretty
fascinating like for example people took
dreams very seriously so if you would
dream of having an object or having a
dog you would go on a Vision Quest
to go find the object that you dreamed
of or a dog so
some sort of exchange happened this way
but the funnier one
the funnier one this is a direct quote
hilarious sentence women in indigenous
North American societies were in
venerate gamblers oh yeah so
they aren't gambling for money but
they're gambling for jewelry and [__]
you know women be accessorizing since 10
000 BC
I mean they would they would basically
have games nights where you'd meet with
like the next Village over girls night
games night
you know they don't change
there's a huge a human Universal where
they go and Gamble yeah exactly they go
gamble for jewelry so this is how shell
an alternate story of how shells got
from Mexico to to Ohio or Amber's
another one they talk about so you know
the easy picture is to say oh they're
using rare items this is exchange
they're trying to create a market and
they
a little perhaps not totally
convincingly but they say there's
totally other explanations for how these
objects or Metals got from one place to
another yeah I mean they don't say that
there was no Market because I don't
think you could prove that well I think
if you follow the Marxist argument about
what a capitalist society looks like
then you have that sort of impersonal
form of rulership and you have
a labor market and all that stuff so
like clearly that's not developed
earlier on right it's like the same
thing you know Marx is wrong because
well they had money in ancient Greece uh
well money was not the [__] same
thing in ancient Greece as it was today
was it the markets were not the same
thing they were not they were not like
the drivers of all social change yeah
this made me think of bodras critique of
Marx actually because he wants to
reintroduce the notion of symbolic value
where things are not tied to production
and consumption as much as they are tied
to gift giving or you could in this case
compacts and obligations kind of between
people yeah or sacrifice are these
things that don't fit into simply the
logic of exchange and use like death
related rituals and things which we tend
to
get out of sight now we don't like death
we don't like like any of that but
what to do with your dead people was
obviously an enormously important thing
and not a very productive thing either
yeah but Beau girard's right to see that
as a kind of underside of of the not the
symbolic but the sort of
sign regime well we are left with though
is an alternative story that just says
this is more complicated it's written
for a public audience I I think which
I'm cool with that story which is a good
story to read but then you inevitably at
the end of the episode you kind of get
to well what do we do with this what is
what is the point of this I mean I want
to re-action keep reading the book
because I think like I'm interested just
from uh pure kind of like normal
curiosity about history and
archaeological evidence like I'm curious
if they come up because I my
understanding was they do talk about
examples of societies that are more
complicated because okay like setting
aside the capitalism question like my
understanding was that
you know that there's uh there's this
war there's this idea and they even
mentioned at the beginning in the
introduction right that oh like you know
you either have like egalitarianism at a
really small scale or once you get to a
bigger scale like there's this problem
of scale that they seem to want to
attack and I'm really curious if they
have examples of large-scale
civilizations that are very egalitarian
and my understanding was that maybe
there were some examples of that later
in the book because that is something
that I will say like
you know whatever however we're defining
roussoian versus have Asian whatever but
I I do think that I I do find the
problem of scale to be a serious problem
a scale and complexity where I don't
really see how you could have
um no hierarchy but like a really large
complicated scale I just I don't know I
can't imagine it and maybe that's my
lack of imagination but
their argument is um oh my God for that
it's um Mexico it's not the Aztecs
though is it because they are they were
not egalitarian they're the the ones
that built the temples
like the Temple of the Sun the Temple of
the Moon the Temple of the snake
uh it's near Mexico
and they apparently what they did again
this is like another going back and
forth in the beginning they built these
big ass [__] temples and they found
like ritual killing burials in the
bottoms of the temples and apparently
around
third fourth Century A.D they just
closed the temples and they redirected
funds from building Monumental
architecture like that to Social and
they became much more egalitative so
sorry sorry to interrupt but the I the
idea here is that they to to build these
Grand there was some form of hierarchy
with religion with some Priestly class
which is presumed to be a more advanced
form but they shut it all down so they
deduce that you know something wasn't
working so they in the linear narrative
they would have reverted to a less
advanced form but what the Davids are
saying is that this was a variable
ongoing negotiable process not a linear
progression from one stage to the next
age one Age Two H3 and that they have
both social forms
the money basically goes to where the
biggest projects decided by the elites
it goes there but then there's other
City forms that have much less
hierarchical much more either temporary
structures where they'll actually just
break up and move out of the city or
they'll have a kind of egalitarian City
where there's no rulership or a rotating
rulership or something like that
uh like shared office kind of stuff like
uh Ancient Ancient Rome uh collegiality
um but those are still considered like
not a complex large like Society you
know what I mean like something with
big infrastructure projects and large I
mean you know because like if you want
to have an answer to the question of how
do we like deal with modern conditions
and and like you kind of need to have
some story about complex infrastructure
complex social organizations that are
bigger than a tribal level right well
then again we should look at the um
that that's perfect those are per that's
a perfect question and so we can look at
so in the context of hunter-gatherers we
look at go Buckley Tepe like Monumental
architecture right so if you're thinking
that during that time people lived in
bands of 10 to 20 people then it'd be
[__] impossible to understand how
people built these places with 15 ton
blocks right same with even with like
the they actually have a new story to
tell about
um the Stonehenge too
uh but the the point there is that
there's a yearly roundabout where the
part of the Year where people you know
the Hunt is good the
shit's on right so they're all gathering
at this place called Blackley Tepe in
Turkey there's a bunch of other sort of
satellite areas too and and they all
come together in this community and then
they split and but there's some evidence
that some people if they're all year
round but generally much lower
population and then suddenly at a
certain time of the year there's a big
ass population and then the point is how
did these places get built in the first
place well there must have been some
kind of social organization that
transcended the 20 10 to 20 people
banned family units right and so we say
okay well then it can't just be the
situation where there are just hunter
gatherers and they're completely
distinct from city building in
agriculture yeah for sure I mean I've
heard about it it's just problematizing
yeah yeah yeah yeah it's it's one of the
oldest sites of monumental architecture
in the planet and you have to think well
how how did it get built isn't it more
isn't that more a question about well
okay there's obviously stuff that was
more than hunter-gatherers but yeah like
I don't know I don't know how that's
more I think about egalitarianism like I
don't know like there's not reason to
think that well that's not on the
egalitarian question that's on the
question of of hunter gatherers not
living in cities or in agriculture oh
sure right like if they had the capacity
to do those things in what's go Blackley
Tepe like 8 000 BCE or something like
that if they had the capacity to do that
then there must have been some like it
can't just be that [__] story of
egalitarian hunter-gather bands that's
that's the point
yeah they also make an aesthetic case
here saying like it's just it's just way
more interesting to be an indigenous
life compared to Western life they
straight up say oh that's a nice that
that's exactly how to get on pills is
good side tell them something's more
interesting exactly this is one cent one
gets the sense that indigenous life was
just a lot more interesting than in a
western town or a city especially by the
way Russo could have written this yeah
especially insofar as the latter
involved or the the western town or city
involves monotonous repetitive
conceptually empty activity the fact is
that we find it hard to imagine how such
an alternative life could be endlessly
engaging and interesting is perhaps more
a reflection on the limits of our
imagination than on the life itself
Rousseau was talking about the division
of labor right and saying doing one
thing sucks yeah this is why we have
Montessori schools based on Emil's
education because Emil's education
division of labor is more efficient not
a single person will argue against that
but it's also Soul draining so you
should be good at a whole bunch of
things which is why despite being more
efficient the division of labor is a
negative thing yes and that's not
something unfortunately that we can just
rewind the clock on it's impossible
except for maybe I don't know giving
people more guaranteed vacation time or
or yeah I don't know what the solution
there is except for something that is
self-help e it's like if you're
depressed and sad and your life's
monotonous go get good at stuff Rousseau
said that though we don't we don't
necessarily need the entire
reconstruction of indigenous societies
from archaeological evidence to tell us
that yeah I reminds me of they quote
Benjamin Franklin too
and he he talks about this phenomenon of
of Indian children being abducted but
them wanting to go back and live at home
again eventually like they can't be
fully socialized quote unquote whatever
but then he says once I remember to have
heard where the person was brought home
to possess a good estate but finding
some care necessary to keep it together
relinquished it to a younger brother
preserving to himself nothing but a gun
and a match coat with which he took his
way again to the Wilderness there's no
conception that you know living without
Plumbing
could actually be better but like what
do you what do you say to a history
where like okay your Europeans come over
they colonize the Americas and then
there's this sort of amazing cultural
discourse between the peoples that have
that is nearly ceased today because we
really need to start recognizing the
sovereignty of indigenous peoples in the
21st goddamn Century but back then okay
there's this huge exchange and and the
critiques of civilization are put in the
the mouths of the indigenous and the the
so-called Noble Savages and Exotics
uh but one of the critiques was that
like they're they're shocked by all the
hopelessness in in European cities and
like they don't have homelessness
I mean I I just cannot imagine that you
know you hear about in East Berlin or
something before the the Wall comes down
there's no homelessness in in communist
countries because if you don't have a
job you get assigned one that could not
be the case without that kind of
bureaucracy yeah yeah there's uh so
what's this other critique about about
homelessness you're not being assigned a
job what the [__] does that mean I don't
understand the indigenous critique just
break your imagination because you can't
imagine not having to work all day to
have somewhere to live
but it's amazing it's so interesting
that they saw these cities they saw the
homelessness and that becomes a critique
of European ideas I don't know these
sorts of ideas just seem to be like
Europe internalized them and now we have
these sort of Social Democratic versus
neoliberal discourses where whether or
not there should be homeless people
whether it's inevitable
but these these have their Origins again
in this Enlightenment period of the
exchanges with the North Americans and
especially this condia act dude who
seems like a [__] badass
yeah the condirox stuff was interesting
you know we can't really get into that
now uh but um but maybe I mean I think
we should do another episode on it I
think we should keep reading yeah I'm
down or maybe yeah that's the good good
episode uh enjoyed the book would
recommend
or learn a lot from it
um and maybe we'll see I mean I look
forward to seeing uh the next chapters
to see if maybe I get a bit more of an
answer to my central question yeah it
might unstick us from our old views but
it won't tell us anything to do and if
you do read it remember this is
roussoian despite the fact that they
just lamb based him I know yeah they're
a bit harsh I mean later they do say
some stuff about how he was probably the
founder of left-wing thought but they
don't even actually say it in like a
nice way necessarily yeah they kind of
just say Hobbs is right wing and
leftists prefer I don't even know how
you how you define Freedom as a value or
like the ER value of humanity without
Rousseau
anyway oh this they have their Anarchist
way of doing that which we can there's
three of them which we can look at next
week thanks everybody we will talk to
you talk thank you very much later wait
I have a new topic I want to dive into
it no I'm just kidding I'm just gonna no
thanks bye I mean you wish you wish
[Music]